اكسير الحياه مشاهدينا هو ما يسعى اليه
كثيرون ومنهم عادل دافعا هي ام للالتزام
بقواعد صحيه صارمه احيانا مش عابر لكن ما
الذي يجعل البعض يعيشون حتى 100 سنه دون
الالتزام بنظام غذائه باحثون من جامعه
كوبنهاج يكشفون السر في دراسه اجريت على
مجموعه من المعمرين الياباني الباحثون
وجدوا ان مزيجا من البكتيريا المعويه
والفيروسات البكتيريه لهؤلاء المعمرين
اليابانيين ربما يكون السبب لتمتعهم
بحمايه افضل من الامراض المرتبطه
بالشيخوخه تستنتج الدراسه التي نشرت
نتائجها في مجله سانزلي بان فهم هذا
التاثير سيساعد الباحثين في الاقتراح اكثر
من فهم كيف يمكننا زياده متوسط العمر
المتوقع ورسم خارطه للبكتيريا المعويه وال
فيروسات البكتيريه لكبار السن
[موسيقى]